my parents abandoned me and I'm really
scared of
abandoned I would really like to see
both of you doing individual therapy
Brandon's mom gets real with him and
Mary about what they need to do so they
won't continue to pass their dysfunction
onto their unborn child a moment that
actually brings Mary and Brandon's mom
closer after 2 years of tension thank
you for that no one's did it no one's
did that to me before so this is 90day
replay travel size where I pack in all
you need to know while keeping it light
hey 90day fans fam it's melissia this
episode surprised me I didn't expect for
Brandon's mom and Mary to have a
breakthrough ever since Brandon's mom
arrived in the Philippines for their
wedding it's been so much animosity
between those two Brendan's mom arrived
here in kandon and to me it's been so
awkward
Brandon will you come here please your
mom is not talking to me at all I'm on
your side I can't feel it they've been
having Brandon frazzled stressed what
I'm trying to do is not have a fight
break out between them at the top of
this week's episode Brandon's mom who
has been in the Philippines for a day
sits down to eat dinner with Mary and
her grandmother and Brandon then on the
menu some frog legs that Mary whipped up
and I'm not going to lie if I was
Brandon's mom I would be hesitant to eat
those things not because they're frog
legs but because Mary cooked them I'm
not saying Mary would poison anybody all
I'm saying is that if I was in Brandon's
mom's shoes the way she and Mary have
been going at it it would have crossed
my mind Brandon's mom goes on to try the
frog legs and is it delicious mhm she
doesn't like it it's written all over
her face yeah you like it mhm it's good
it tastes like
chicken and look at Mary's face
Brandon's mom has her eye twitching and
everything fast forward in the episode
Brandon takes his mom out to try street
food and she experiences some major
culture shock they have chicken liver
chicken heart um chicken blood chicken
feet Chicken
Heads chicken it looks like intestins no
that's this one okay when Brandon and
his mom finally sit down to eat she
tells him she can't believe he lives in
the Philippines I think it just goes to
show that you just never know where your
life could end up and things get deep
fast she brings up her addiction just
like I never ever would have imagined in
my life that I would have become an
addict
[Music]
I did not think that either I couldn't
believe it and Brandon opens up more
about how traumatizing it was for him
when I was 14 years old my siblings like
they're like 5 and 3 years old and my
mom was starting to disappear from the
house for long periods at a time and
then I would be left alone with the kids
to take care of them and watch over them
So eventually the DHS comes in they take
me my brother and my sister
away and that whole time I was in denial
of my mom being a drug
addict it screwed with me mentally it
really messed up all of our Lives wow I
can only imagine how bad that screwed
with him most kids have an idea of who
their parents are and to find out that
they are drastically different from what
you think in such an Abrupt way So
eventually the DHS comes in they take me
my brother and my sister away it's
heartbreaking and think about being 14 a
kid yourself and wondering where your
mom is but you have to put that aside
because you have to step into the adult
role and take care of your siblings that
has to be so scary for him and
unfortunately it has been or it is a
reality for a lot of kids out there I'm
really happy that you started recovery
and you're like 18 months clean now
wow she's somewhat new to her sobriety
that's a huge accomplishment though keep
it going Miss Angela the thing about it
is you don't just treat addiction by not
using you treat it by creating a life
that makes it easier not
to the only thing that would make it
more I guess complete in a sense is the
rebuilding of a relationship with you
Brandon tells his mom the only way to
reestablish a good relationship with him
again is to bond with
[Music]
Mary especially now that they're having
a kid you know like Mary didn't have her
mom she never had the type of person
that would give her guidance and like
you got to have her
back I understand what you're saying so
I will try to build a healthy
relationship with Mary Brandon's mom
says as long as she sees improvements
with Mary jealousy and toxicity she will
be cool but if not we would have a major
problem she's like that was my baby
first I brought him into this world and
as we'll see shortly she seems to also
be aware that her actions have played a
part in him being in such a toxic
relationship I appreciate that you are
willing to give me a shot at being your
mom even though you are in a position
where you are becoming a dad you can
tell she is serious about her
relationship with her son
she listened to exactly what he said in
order to reestablish a good relationship
with me
again you need to connect and bond with
Mary she never had the type of person
that would give her guidance and like
you got to have her back and executed it
giving some good guidance at that Mary
is 24 weeks pregnant so earlier today we
got the first sonogram since she got
pregnant Mary Brandon and his mom go to
dinner and Brandon's mom gets the
privilege to reveal to Brandon and Mary
the gender of their baby and the doctor
hid the baby's gender in a plastic
envelope so my mom can read it to us out
loud as a way to include my mom but
before they get into the festivities of
it all Brandon's mom gets down to
business you have now started the family
clear across the
world
that
I'm
not I'm not going to be a part of
so and that is my
fault but I'm just going to keep it real
here dang I know that's tough she's
clearly seeing the negative consequences
of her decisions but she's facing them
not making any excuses which I respect
I'm just going to keep it real
here you come
from what I believe to be a
dysfunctional environment you come from
a dysfunctional family as
well as much as I know that you guys
love each other it's not
enough because when you
haven't dealt with all the things that
you grew up learning it just becomes
this repeated pattern facts who knows
what Brandon's mom dealt with or
experienced growing up in side note
shout out to all of you out there who
are choosing or have chosen to break
unhealthy generational patterns your
bloodline thanks you it just becomes
this repeated pattern you know I I
definitely hear you there and we are
trying to work on it because when I was
in America it was almost a fight every
day
I remember right so but here slowly but
surely we are getting better at it also
me I'm trying to be better myself
because even now I'm still overthinking
and I can't handle it you're handling it
Mary you're breathing you're still alive
I get that it might be hard but I can
guarantee you the way you're talking
about it hence your choice of words and
I can't handle it makes it even harder
my parents abandon me and
I'm really scared of
ab I would really like to see both of
you doing individual therapy the things
that you struggle with like the fear of
Abandonment overthinking um Brandon has
his own things you know um anger and
codependency when you guys work on those
separately I promise you that together
you will function better she's like look
I might not have been perfect but those
mistakes taught me some things and I'm
about to tell you what I know that's
terrific advice Miss Angela now let's
hope they listen I'm more than willing
to do that and and if Mary is willing to
like commit to therapy like
alongside then that would that would
mean a
lot I'm willing to and also I'm really
thankful that you give us advice and
it's it helps me a lot you and GES from
brendon's Mom so really means a lot to
me thank you for that no one's did it no
one's did that to me before
so oh
progress thank you for listening and
thank you for cons considering you know
that we'll promise you we'll do
that good yeah I would think that the
more Brandon and Mary work on resolving
their own issues the more they can enjoy
their child hopefully they keep that
promise now that everyone is in a good
mood it's time for the gender reveal
Brandon's mom pulls out the envelope and
ready
oh
oh my gosh it's a girl no it's a
girl you know what I mean right yeah so
Mary said it was going to be a boy and
Brandon said it's a girl since Brandon
is right he gets to smash pie in Mary's
face people get all types of creative
when it comes to gender reveals
nowadays ready yeah
[Music]
go w
you're eat oh no oh hell no
what
you so it's fair that's
fair a a baby can really bring families
together at the same time if you have
terrible communication adding another
human being to the mix won't take away
the drama for long next week things turn
sour between Mary and Brandon
again Brandon told me where to find you
brenon and I are supposed to get married
tomorrow but this morning we got a huge
fight over
money right now I'm 50/50 of marrying
Brandon because we don't have a plan for
our future yeah you don't when you
picture your life can you imagine
raising this baby without
[Music]
him keep keeping it real Miss
Angela at least she and Mary still seems
to be in a better place all right 90day
fan spam thanks for hanging with me make
sure you sitick with ET because we are
covering it all I will see you next
[Music]
time